[Applause]
[Music]
in September of 2017 Puerto Rico
suffered its most significant natural
disaster in the last 100 years
the impact of Hurricane Maria a huge
category for cyclone a category 5 at its
strongest with wind gusts of over a
hundred and fifty five miles per hour
and torrential rain wreaked havoc on
this islands the destruction it was
enormous thousands of houses were
destroyed in the entire puerto rican
electricity network collapsed the
islands was quite literally engulfed in
darkness as you can imagine the economic
damage was enormous to give you an idea
today the reconstruction costs have
risen to around 100 billion dollars
[Music]
and that's not all seven months later
thousands of businesses remain closed
and blackouts are still quite frequent
however did you are just waiting on
because Hurricane Maria might stop the
whole story
[Music]
the truth is that the islands problems
began a really long time ago
Puerto Rico they've been suffering a
severe economic crisis and a population
exodus for more than ten years an exodus
so great that it threatens the islands
very survival see after declaring
bankruptcy in May of 2017 the situation
has become so critical that the islands
government is considering moving
thousands of prisoners to private
prisons in the United States so why is
this while the islands government is
even having problems with financing its
own penitentiary system and renting
spots in places like Texas or Florida is
actually proving to be cheaper
now hold on just a moment here I mean
prisoners to the United States it sounds
kind of weird but you absolutely heard
it right do not forget the Puerto Rico
is a part of the United States it's not
a state but it's kind of a tree
Associated State and of course by being
a part of the United States having a
tropical climate a rich history and
beautiful white sand beaches on which by
the way Captain Jack Sparrow had some of
his most famous exploits we might think
that Puerto Rico has everything required
to be one of the most prosperous places
in the world well the reality is not so
much the truth is really rather
different so dear viewer here's a
question for you where do you think most
cuarto Ricans live I mean it sounds like
a bit of a silly question but it isn't
because the answer it's not Puerto Rico
[Music]
the escape yes a first Puerto Rico may
look like a paradise good weather
beautiful beaches wonderful music
however the island has a huge problem
every year thousands and thousands of
Puerto Ricans leave the island see
Puerto Ricans have been US citizens
since 1917 they are Americans and they
can move freely around that country well
according to data from the Pew Research
Center during the last decade more than
500,000 Puerto Ricans have left Puerto
Rico to move to the continents to places
like Texas Florida New York and
Pennsylvania half a million people is an
absolutely huge number for an island
that has just over three million
inhabitants seen in another way only in
the last ten years one of every seven
inhabitants has left grata Rico rather
the question I just asked where do you
think most Preta Ricans lived while the
answer is that since 2006 there are more
Puerto Ricans living in the continental
United States than there are on the
island specifically more than five
million compared to just over three we
are watching a real live demographic and
population collapse on a monumental
scale Lyman stone an independent
migration researcher and economist at
the US Agriculture Department and things
well they could get much much worse
the islands own government expects just
in 2018 for another 200,000 people to
leave the island
this means that Puerto Rico will lose
about 6 percent of its population in a
single year
[Music]
so if you thought this process this
Exodus was already severe well the
consequences of Hurricane Maria have
only accelerated us different estimates
both from the government and from
private consultants expect another half
million Puerto Ricans to pack their bags
and move to the continents in the next
five years I'm very attached to my
island and my preference is to stay here
but I have to think about what's best
for my son
Victor Dominguez a 39 year old mortgage
banker to the Washington Post as you may
imagine such a flights will have very
serious consequences for the island
especially because most of those who are
leaving a young in fact it is estimated
that half of all immigrants of all
people who leave the islands are under
24 years of age so what's the result of
all of this well in the next decade
Puerto Rico's population will decreased
2.5 million people that is to say in the
next decade Puerto Rico will lose 800
thousand inhabitants 25 percent of its
population
[Music]
and if another natural disaster another
hurricane for example occurs or if the
island fails to recover from the severe
crisis is going through the reality
could be even worse I mean can you
imagine what this will mean for the
islands economy who is going to pay its
huge debt who's going to pay for its
pensions
[Music]
but I think at this point in the video
we need to ask a question why do so many
Puerto Ricans leave the island
these statistics seem to be similar to
that of a country going through a war so
what's going on well listen to this
[Music]
a very long crisis
so if we take a look at the data the
explanation seems very clear almost half
of Puerto Ricans living on the islands
are considered poor by US standards the
average family income is just twenty
thousand dollars which is slightly less
than half of the average income of mrs.
zippy the poorest state in the
continental United States
[Music]
but that's not all the islands
government is bankrupt and it has a huge
public debt seventy billion dollars and
another fifty billion dollars in payment
commitments like for example it's
pensions around that we're talking about
an island of just over 3 million
inhabitants so that's really an insane
amount of money this means that an
average family would have to devote six
years of their salary to pay off the
public debt so now you might be able to
understand why Puerto Rico is known as
the Greece of the Caribbean and if you
think this is the worst of it when
you're absolutely wrong the worst part
is that there's hardly any work in
Puerto Rico in fact the island has the
lowest activity rate in the United
States only 4 out of every 10 adults are
actively looking for work and if we
don't count the people who don't have a
job in the public sector whose salaries
come out of the taxes the people who
work in the private sector provide the
results it's pretty alarming less than a
quarter of the islands inhabitants work
in the private sector
[Music]
by the way one of Puerto Rico's great
problems is precisely this public
employees and officials see almost one
out of every four jobs on the island
corresponds to the government and that's
not the worst part did you know that
many of these public employees had the
right to retire at the age of 50 which
is 15 years earlier than in the rest of
the United States
[Applause]
[Music]
and if you want things to get even more
terrifying you can also keep in mind so
that given the high percentage of young
people leaving the islands population is
aging very very quickly in other words
if things don't change Puerto Rico will
enter a very very difficult situation
but okay I'm sure at this point in the
video you're wondering well how on earth
can the island get out of this mess is
there really a way out for Puerto Rico
well let's have a look
[Music]
how to get out of this it's often said
that those who don't learn from history
are condemned to repeat it
and indeed this might happen in Puerto
Rico when we talk about how local
politicians see the future we find some
good things but also some not-so-good
things
Puerto Rico has gone bankrupt that's the
facts and if they continue like this the
government could push the islands into
the abyss so for one public spending has
to be cast they have to stop the
drainage that has caused such a huge
amount of public debt and in principle
the new government Ricardo Rocio is
working on this in fact he's committed
to decreasing the government size by a
lot the problem is how he wants to do it
isn't exactly clear indeed it's not
really clear if there's a real political
will to correct the island's massive
problems
for another puerto rico has to turn its
economic policy around and set some
serious plans in motion in order to
attract investments this is because
Puerto Rico needs decisive measures it
needs real reforms and not just cosmetic
changes a few things have been done in
recent years for example they're trying
to turn Puerto Rico into a kind of
financial center that guarantees
anonymity to international investors
[Music]
this could work but there's still a
really long way to go now before we end
today's video we still have to ask a
very important question how on earth did
Puerto Rico get to this point well one
reason was that local government spends
huge amounts of money to hire as we saw
many public workers and to fund
expensive projects that didn't give the
island anything other than more debt the
other reason has a lot to do with
influence from the United States but
that's something we're going to tell you
about in an upcoming video for now it's
your turn because I want to ask a
question of you do you think the Puerto
Rico should continue to belong to the
United States or do you think they
should seek to become an independent
country well you can leave your answer
in the comments below as well as in this
survey and I really hope you've enjoyed
that video please do hit like if you did
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday also don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
Media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]
[Applause]